you
okay so dozen more entered 43 all right
so let's let's get this let's try to get
top three see what we get I'm guessing
confetti is the new the new thing here I
love ski so alright we're gonna have a
move and now I'm mover to start I'll
take a quick W you've got 20 seconds to
make the first move
no way Oh back to tournament and just
like that we got a W in there I'll take
it oh man alright that's a that's a
great start
alright we're gonna get a mover a mover
alright open Sicilian let's go straight
in for an exchange let's strike it a
five right away more preparing that are
we a little scary
I should've played Queen e1 yeah no good
man no good
I'm gonna go Queen h4 I have to give up
the exchange already sad
oh my god how getting made on each - oh
man so sad so sad
nice I'm not weaseling out of this oh
wow
I didn't want to do that you better fly
man
I got a tricky night
it's extra tricky man extra tricky got
the pawn no trades man no trades that
nights cover and everything you got this
man you got this
I had the ruck there down on time oh so
bad may not each to was staring at me I
just I was just ready to float my mouse
over there and just resigned yeah you're
gonna want to rethink that uh that
opening buddy I'm talking to myself
the buddy here in this case is me Wow
may not h2o I just getting forked now I
guess that wasn't their plan all along
Wow what's this infatuation with d3 I
understand holy cow pieces are dropping
left and right oh my goodness there goes
another one I don't have any answers I
don't have any answers here made on D -
there we go back to tournament we got
eight oh man okay 95 players where did
that come from
people get word of this surprise uh this
new thing that happens if you get top
three let's see alright let's let's hit
the clean here I guess there's no time
for a Bishop f4
let's castle let's not get made it on
each two or even be in a position where
that could happen man that was scary
we're getting some material No
let's take that actually I want to make
sure I keep my light square Bishop he is
just too valuable to give up let's go
for a queen trade occupy the D file
let's secure my night post first yeah
let's just double up I have pressure on
b5 which makes a 5 B force stuff
difficult I'm ok what a queen exchange
bishop here Oh interesting
let's let's do that the material back
sneak over I don't know about that my
rooks are struggling to do stuff let's
just oh they were too quick to move
there now we're up a full rook the
knight moves I got this prove the king
we got this they resigned
back to tournament who okay we got 12 12
8 8
and fire less than 20 minutes left okay
and we have a Scandinavian opening I
have to say opening I've received a
youtube comment once I said it like that
and then someone is like that player
isn't Scandinavian no the opening man
the opening the opening all right so the
Queen's having a tough day you're gonna
have a follow-up fork they could get
this guy back but I'll rip the heart out
of their structure can you know where is
he at
uh-huh so let's continue with an attack
I want to get up that 87 pond I'm gonna
take here and eliminate him let's just
do this
the Queen's off let's ask him a question
actually I could mate with a knight on
c6 now that my pawn is defended so this
is serious they're defending against
that I'm threatening mate
Bishop h2 is a move I'm on the bishop
they missed the mate back to tournament
16 ten ten eight many eights
okay a hundred and fourteen are entered
in this one there were 31 just a little
bit ago okay
this guy's flying hmm very very fast I'm
too afraid of a sacrifice in age six
prepare to give this guy up let's grab
that dark square Bishop ah let's break
it the dark squares a little bit maybe
get to the C file let's reposition my
knight
let's take here actually and then here
and then here here
Knight here I could still move my queen
and defend the night we're gonna have a
messed up structure I want to make sure
the Queen's are off the board so even
pretty much on the clock just a matter
of converting this fast we're entering
we have a fantastic structure pile up
grab this guy next I'm gonna try to hunt
him down I have a five second lead and a
rook f4 simplify it run away upon let's
not allow the rook to get active you
know just keep pushing him get behind
him
miss that they they move there no
stalemates they're down on time back to
tournament we go
okay that guy was really flying early on
2014 12 12 is where we're out 120 are
now in this one 15 less than less than
16 left in this one all right let's
let's try D 5 okay let's get C 5 in the
mix okay Bishop f5 e3 some simple stuff
let's get on a file that is soon to be
open and right here seems more active
huh and I could look to expand on the
queenside now the B 4 a 5 B 4 playing
the side where I have some space 94 is a
good follow up this pawn isn't a pin I
could look to a breakthrough on that
point maybe not a bad idea
I could still try for it even though
it's not hitting with check this comes
to mind now playing on both wings it's
pretty committal move but I'm gonna do
it just to flush him out of there I'm
gonna take with the rook because I want
him to enter next winning some material
now definitely take with the F pond um
let's just back up I could win the Queen
if they took I'd bishop base to Knight
g3 and I could win this pawn oh let's
just kick came out of there
if I did this Knight d4 just helps to
helps him to improve yeah let's just
double I have a ton of pawns
break down this structure tsunami
fons tsunami upon's in the chat we have
a tsunami of pawns on board right now
and we're getting the Queen they're down
on time back determined 24 16 14 128
less than 14 minutes left I got many
games and of course I was helped with
that game one another Scandinavian
opening okay this is another another
approach to not be too quick to play
your Knight to c3 of course in the end I
guess I end up doing that home trying to
take advantage of the king now let's go
here and then here in the night and an
open position pins are that much more
uncomfortable uncomfortable so how are
they weaseling out of that it's avoid
the Queen exchange get the other rook
here I think their queen will find it
more difficult to find a safe Square so
potential well there's a bishop in I
could take their clean now but they get
me back I'm on their queen again could
take their Bishop on Knight takes Knight
or here I don't think it's working out
and the King could run to e7 if I tried
for that I think so I'm gonna win
something still I believe yeah and I was
boxed out by my bishop they resigned
back to term in 28 2016 16 12 minutes 12
seconds left
131 in this one all right Huck we have a
French on board
an advanced French we're I'm up a tempo
actually because this guy is gonna have
to spend another move to get to c5 I
guess they're gonna trade light square
bishop soon they would be dropping a
piece if they did that other dark
squares are having a tough day my plan
here is to get rid of their dark square
bishop
and then drop drop a night into f6
threatening a skewer let's go here to
reinforce d4 I'm anticipating that that
will be a focal point I definitely want
to keep Queens on okay phase one dark
square Bishop Sargon my worst piece is
this clown here so let's get him working
in to e5
he hits here with tempo and we got
everything covered all my base points
are covered my queen guards all these
pawns Queen on g7 would be nice I look
to get to the seventh rank let's get him
out of there has come another question
in between air you get to the seventh
right away I don't see any reason not to
go straight in for that okay probably
feeling a little bit uncomfortable um
let's do this not quite sure what this
move is doing a queen on e5 would be
nice it could take here I don't know is
it necessary Queen on e5 soon let's just
get the Queen's off and they don't have
any time either they're down on time
yeah that was tough very very difficult
to work around that night he found good
homes a lot of our holes dark square
holes and they were without their dark
square bishop all right let's try
Sicilian open Sicilian Knight Orff
okay not be 5 in this case
let's go B 5 B 4 there's no reason I
shouldn't take with the bishop there
let's let's pull him back to be a little
bit cautious of a sacrifice here and
then here I have this square covered at
least with the piece prepared to give
him up I must give him up defending the
rook a knight on c4 would be quite good
coupled with a5 a4 don't want a castle
okay
oops clean trade guess we're gonna get
that in there huh okay let's get active
pigs are officially on the second oh boy
got mate coming up or doing
probably could have done better here
Bishop on d4 yeah that's what we're
gunning for and then discoveries
actually this I think is an idea now
they're gonna push no they didn't I got
a mate next they needed to push there
ooh stay away from that checkmark they
offered a dry by mistake I imagine
yeah they resigned but I was ready to
click on that arrow thinking it was like
the back to tournament button or the
return to tournament okay they go at d3
I'm gonna hold off on counseling cuz I
don't want to allow for the typically
five and then kill my king tactics I
guess here no I shouldn't have done that
I need to keep the square open for my
knight yeah that was a bit silly
maybe Queen needed to come back home I'm
gonna push the pawn lets rule that out
altogether now this manoeuvre is ruled
out let's advance yeah let's go Queen
side maybe even take once more queen g4
Bishop h4 stuff when I keep my dark
square bishop he's pointing at g3 now
they're very sensitive on the dark
squares he's dropping and Bishop on e3
would be killer
he's weaseling in there they have to
give up the exchange at least that's
what I'm guessing Oh
there goes the Queen and Queen G for
just what is with that uh-oh
they were being sneaky oh I'm gonna be
trolled now everyone knows my instinct
is to just quickly come over there and
click on something we got 40 less than
seven minutes left
40/29 28 25 149 are in this one
let's try with efore oops idea not just
my mousepad there let's take again yeah
I already played this guy is this the
same this is the same guy the one where
I lucked out yeah let's look now right
now is a perfect time to look during the
game similar to what you did and trying
to change your settings at one time
during a game wonderful timing you've
got wonderful timing
all right let's get a flight square and
rule out my major pieces from coming
here
they got to go back to f6 don't drop
your bishop he's important Bishop g4 no
Queen III hit the Queen Wow Inbetweeners
let's double up seize control of this
file I could do a push I'm on the a5
pawn but this move scares me all right
we're gonna do this first yeah I should
have offset their night
he's scary man it's no way around it's
just how it is he's scary
mm yeah it's just continually throwing
punches
okay I want an outside pass pawn really
soon I have a time edge save him I got
this now free move that actually just
keep going with him they timed out back
determined forty four twenty-nine
twenty-eight hundred and fifty five
players
four minutes and change it's looking
like we're gonna see this surprise
ending some kind of new something fancy
I guess something different happens if
you get top three
okay we have a pond an extra pawn on c4
let's look to open up this bishops eyes
at the right moment I want to do it too
quick because they can meet c5 with to
d5 I want to make sure these guys are
exchanged I'd like that to happen
tonight into here would be good this
will officially break them up
oh I guess they missed that I was on the
bishop get him next number one priority
his past pawn 95 and then c5 let's go
here actually defend this guy and then
here and then scoop him up yep let's go
straight in for this I have my
background cover there's nothing going
on with this their Knight is having a
tough day let's defend this pawn create
a flight square with g6 I've set this
file and he's now past
they have back ranked issues if they
capture let's enter let's defend this
pawn for one more move I guess they
could kick them away huh let's enter
Queen here is better I'm threatening f2
with that
OOP
okay
like
push that was a silly move by me there
down in time back to termined 48 two
minutes two seconds left 48 with fire 29
is next 28 159 in this one
okay
let's see what you got I guess this is
gonna be the last one try to get 52
points all right where's the Queen gonna
go hmm oh I should have asked him a
question first there's nothing here for
me
it's just a nothing type position
inject some life into it with the
structural change avoid the Knights
Queen G for Knight f6 stuff and then
made on g7 rook up and over he's going
to try to go here
let's do this right away
and then this move next yeah it wasn't
really the right idea was it
look up and over yeah
quit bothering me man this was so silly
how I'm playing this right now is silly
look at my clean terribleness
terribleness
can you phone ending
and we have four seconds
they're down on time just before the
game that
back-ended what is this what's the
ending here oh there it is first place
confetti oh there it is man I haven't
seen this in so long first place
confetti look at it's just going away
slowly that's pretty cool man oh man the
top three get to see that I guess first
place confetti cool in the end one
hundred and sixty two were entered in
this one I had 52:29 was next another 29
28 etc alright let's go through all the
pages and I know I still haven't
adjusted it so that the number 10 guy is
seen as I cycled through but alright
I'll get to see the majority it's two
three a lot of pages to go through in
the end 162 and somebody on YouTube
inform me after how many tournaments
I've put out there on YouTube competing
in tournaments someone finally said to
me you know when you say good games all
you know you're always you're including
yourself when you say good games like to
the 162 of you good games all really
it's to the 161 of you somebody was
someone was being super technical or
anything to the 161 of you good games
all right
you